oh my god it jacksepticeye ah hey how's
it going brahs welcome back to another
episode of resident evil
7 alright so right off the bat I read
you bros comments and apparently there's
a little hidden hidden little secret
down here that I missed completely so I
appreciate the little tips and tricks
that you bros give me what do we have a
box
hell yeah [ __ ] all right nice
little creepy shed there appreciate it
now we have I guess we have a broken
handgun and a broken shotgun I'm just
gonna repair the broken hang on cuz I
can't be bothered to go and get the
broken shotgun is that okay with you
great great I'm glad we agree on things
broken handgun all right great
you said on the repair kit excellent
oh they have different max okay okay
okay
more ammo for me so anything else we
need I think we're good to rock and roll
[ __ ] let's do this we're going
to the party
hell yeah I used to work at a nightclub
so ah I know what I handle [ __ ] up
drunk people oh my god is bleach I mean
hey bro doesn't even love it hey boots
hey bro
it's a [ __ ] nice atmosphere in there
a lot of hosts a lot of [ __ ] go up go
on in all right all right bro man bleeds
just such a bro who would have thought
let's play
yay oh how nice all right
I can't play for too long today because
I know she doesn't understand I don't
want to go back to how things turn back
the clock so Ethan Ethan yes that's me
you can crawl around underneath that
filthy rotten house oh you all looking
for them ingredients but you ain't gonna
find a goddamn thing Ethan right buddy
you'll need that serum baby oh maybe
you're gonna have to come through me oh
I'll come through you what do you say I
come through your wit mine yeah
ah [ __ ] nice [ __ ] nice
[ __ ] indeed alright so we have a new gun
let's suppose we don't have any again ah
[ __ ] a relatively powerful great great
just [ __ ] drink how does it look
looks pretty cool you should have
upgraded this shotgun
god dammit why didn't you tell me then
huh oh jeez set a trap oh my god it's a
box
hang on mo what if you're just going and
Eve Hey a5 [ __ ] yeah hey I have no
friends right on her ass nicely placed
mate nicely placed not very discreet
though but nicely placed Oh got another
one [ __ ] they're everywhere
hey Beryl how you doing you look pretty
good man can I crawl underneath [ __ ] it
got a cold man wait there's a treasure
hidden here I recognize this place
what oh yeah what what whoa oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there's a trap in the [ __ ]
ceiling
okay so now we can repair the shotgun -
that's pretty good
I don't know why we need to do that can
I shoot it from here I don't [ __ ]
trust this no it was pretty [ __ ]
obvious
hey barrel how you doing you look pretty
good alright so what else we got huh
nothing if them but I Betty box when you
favorite catchphrase everyone box I
goddamn it [ __ ] sake what so the boxes
I've explodes off of what's over here
nothing great God
shut the [ __ ] up
why is this here what the [ __ ] let us
make it I don't need this many guns
right I don't know man
there we go actually I don't need to
hold the repair kit either [ __ ] sake
we'll go get the broken shotgun later
this is perfect timing
what how am I supposed to know no
[ __ ] password right try zero eight
one full okay sure
zero six two one that's II know it's
zero five one four oh come on take your
chance you never know
[Music]
What did he say zero one five I have a
bad feeling about this
the [ __ ] did you do well Jase ass for
[ __ ] sake
ah come on I don't ah wait just great
just [ __ ] fantastic
I don't [ __ ] trust boxes anymore you
were my only friend Anna came you were
supposed to meet a chosen one there you
go [ __ ] great tried to shoot them
from now on I don't I don't know man
Hey look at that shotgun burn your fuel
I don't need it great this corridor it's
way too [ __ ] setup
anytime you got a long ass [ __ ]
corridor there's a trap there's in it
yeah I see it
that's right [ __ ] here got him Jesus
Christ oh god watch out for the trap you
[ __ ]
Jesus you almost got hurt [ __ ]
hello I was handing you lemons to make
lemonade then oh god oh god moist
monsters what the [ __ ] oh my god baby I
missed
Oh God Rilla Rilla reload got'em get
[ __ ] see Jesus Christ
are they still left come on dear
just [ __ ] die you [ __ ] pancake
looking [ __ ] I'm just gonna go
not gonna waste my [ __ ] ammo
alright this place looks wonderful isn't
it
Jesus Christ so sick of the [ __ ] trap
I swear to God if you're a trap box
can't even trust a good old box these
days
is this guy for real can you just [ __ ]
off how [ __ ] die mother [ __ ] Jesus
Christ no more traps I'm [ __ ] done
with traps hey Peggy how you doing hey
you had to go ahead supporter this looks
like a wide I'm okay nice this looks
like a boss area doesn't it it's too
wide and open
right now oh it's a hub here same
station alright now we can head off in
the world have a good time you know see
what happens see what floats it's not a
trap
I swear to god no more [ __ ] traps but
I just take damage from jumping down
there god dammit all right what do we
got you know what pop some pills popping
them pills some meta fan shotgun shells
you trade one handgun ammo for one shot
yeah it's worth it
alright so we're missing a battery cool
thanks game for telling me appreciate
you there's really nothing else here it
seems like except broken dreams oh there
it is okay I swear to God if you're a
broken yeah [ __ ] you and [ __ ] you Pig
honestly like I swear to God I swear to
God
ah some people pointed out that during
your playthrough while you playing the
game you didn't get a scar on your arm
or some [ __ ] like that
you see I have a scar on my arm I don't
know it's pretty interesting I guess
well we got the battery now I don't
that's a gun
I'm getting really [ __ ] tired of
these [ __ ] traps man no no no [ __ ]
that keep it clean
what the [ __ ] is that [ __ ] you too oh my
god it checks out the guy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah oh yeah bring it on [ __ ]
bring it on that [ __ ] G says crime [ __ ]
you to another one
how are you still alive
are you [ __ ] kidding me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
just [ __ ] die
disgusting you're disgusting oh my god
just steak yes Batman down everybody
ah [ __ ] that mean is more oh I thank you
just took all my innate launcher rounds
all of them
and up we go no ok it's the kind of
thing we're like you know it doesn't
matter what we do we're always gonna
lose cuz we're set up by this
[ __ ] but I don't know man come
on what does that
oh well that's embarrassing not doing
too shabby I would say so hi how are you
doing today then yeah
doing all right having a good day having
a good time
oh look it's you that'd be weird if I
walked in on you while you played that
would be some meta [ __ ] but no offense I
don't think you look like a zombie don't
get me wrong
although honestly I don't know hey how
you doing buddy you're next
what well I thank you kindly I suppose
we hit the stairs almost mr. coin
whoa well after you goddamn it this part
isn't scary it's just [ __ ] annoying
oh do we have the code I didn't I didn't
catch a code sir code back there surely
there must have been boy there we go one
for oa1 408 all right
that's why there was a box here because
we come back to this area all right now
that I used all my [ __ ] nade [ __ ]
rounds can't use that anymore
push back through the flamethrower
wherever it is there good one 408 yeah
we did it
damn it so no cheating that [ __ ] you
carry it get rid of it
[ __ ] you that's the real reason why the
box is there do I really gotta get rid
of know that should you carry it ah
come on man all right maybe all the
weapons how does he know
really you had to get rid of everything
huh oh wait a manic oh thank you did you
know it's my birthday thank you okay so
this is a puzzle that we play it in the
VHS tape which I mean should be pretty
[ __ ] obvious then because all we
gotta really do is I suppose we gotta
walk in here just son start the [ __ ]
puzzle hey it's my birthday everybody
hey about that it's my birthday
shut the [ __ ] up okay kiss my ass that's
kind of creepy
hey that kind of no no oh [ __ ] Jesus
that kind of proves my point
so he set us up to lose now but since we
saw the VHS tape we could win with
cheating that's kind of cool I like that
hey balloons how you doing everybody I
can just see him blowing up all these
balloons loser loser
oh [ __ ] sake loser hey someone's like
we've done this before
how about that
good game GG man now we have the bow
this way the oil one run out and [ __ ]
burn us to death in a horrible way
although I'm not sure how we set up the
[ __ ] valve to break when you'd use it
once creepy
happy birthday yeah it's gonna blow we
knew that why don't we take cover
what the [ __ ] oh god oh [ __ ] put it in
dude and for that I would get away from
the oil if I were you oh well
for you god damn it
[ __ ] okay I can only play a love
but more I'm running out of time
unfortunately this is really cool
oh we got it [ __ ] yeah
excellent dude you look good excellent
yeah I know it's Mia yeah no no we're
just beyond appear all right god damn I
hate him you dead guess that's not the
cards not yet
lucky me look unless you have any more
surprises up your sleeve I suggest you
and I don't do spoilers dick and I don't
know say they did it did it beat it I
guess it would be a good place to end it
here just really kind of want to play a
little bit more I know I'm not supposed
to hey we have a map
I'm really sorry for cutting this one a
little bit short but it's all I could do
for today I hope you enjoyed it
regardless and I'll see you tomorrow
with another longer episode I promise
thank you for watching it means a lot
stay awesome Bruce